- So we're all celebrating
the 20th anniversary
of the release of "Legally Blonde."
And my reaction to "Legally Blonde" is one
of the most watched videos on my channel.
So I thought I'd take this opportunity
to talk about what's accurate
about this fantastic legal movie.
- Girls, I'm going to Harvard.
- [Devin] First of all,
a non pre-law major
gets into law school.
Yes, it happens all the time.
Law schools hate the fact
that they're always accepting pre-law
and poli-sci majors.
They like variety.
- Well, sir, we've never had one before,
and aren't we always
looking for diversity?
- Elle Wood scores almost a perfect score
on the LSAT and gets into Harvard Law.
- 179! (screams in delight)
- Yes, if you score as high
as she did on the LSAT,
you'll probably get into Harvard Law.
- Welcome to Harvard.
- [Devin] Harvard Law
uses the Socratic method
to terrorize students.
Yes, all the time.
Most law schools still do it.
No, it's not a good teaching method,
but they still do it.
And Elle Woods faces sexual harassment
in the legal field.
- Are you hitting on me?
- You're a beautiful girl.
- [Devin] Yes, that still happens.
Yes, it is still despicable.
Hopefully we'll drive this
out of a legal profession.
But that is "Legally Blonde,"
what's accurate 20 years later.